okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about a particular
feature of
language um
[Music]
that is a little bit subtle but it is
atomicity and thread safety
so uh let's see who is
leading this is it roman yes i'm here
okay so the first
is really what we need to build upon and
that is
ensuring that rename file and create
file
are atomic so that there is never any
partial
stuff lying around or that if two
processes tried to rename a file to the
same target
and override target is false then only
one of them
should succeed so let me understand
something
unix shells with with move and things
like that
do they have the safety or not the basic
move operation
is is atomic
but let's say if you create create
output then if another process creates
the same
output file then the two of you will
overwrite each other's files so it's not
i mean it can be done but
not every operation is automatically
atomic
but the underlying operations rename
file and create file
can be made atomic now we didn't do that
because 30 years ago
nobody even knew what atomicity was
right because
all these multi sweating and so is is
fairly new
and so our existing code is not
atomic and apparently and it turns out
it's not trivial to do so because some
distributions that we still support uh
have it's not clear whether they support
the necessary operations i mean
constantine is working on that
don't know whether there's any news and
so what distributions is linux
distributions or what
yes i think the main one is red hat
seven
constantine right so i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure
that the kernel does i mean you won't
have the library support but if you make
the rosters call
yes you can use the cisco yes so
i'm fairly confident that the ones that
we
that are important because they are lts
versions
can be made to uh can be supported here
so you're you're on this and basically
it's just going to be that things like
rename
file become atomic yes that's the main
there's no use of visible changes so
what happens if you try and
if two processors both try and rename a
file and
the second one there does one
it will get an error i mean it will just
say the file already exists
if i mean we have this option right i
mean there are always
rename file doesn't have a file already
exists create files yes
no both both have
oh you mean rename to that destination
yes
i think so so override target whether
it's true or false so we have four cases
right
and whoever loses that battle will get
an error message and then we track
we we we handle that error so that
that's how it gets done
what do you mean by hand do you mean the
code you're the user code handles the
error
yes i mean the the rename file or create
file will return an error
and it's then up to you to to do the
right thing and
for example if you want to use it for
synchronization then you
you set the override target to false so
that only one wins
but if you want atomicity now put your
set rename file to two so both of them
succeed
but there will never be a mix up of the
two files the result will always be
one of the two that tried to write it
well overwrite target is true means
the later one overwrites is that right
yes
but that's i mean but it'll never get
corrupted it'll just be yes
i mean one of them wins at the moment
both may win right and so they will so
you have you have seen your fair share
of these uh error messages gobbled
gobbled local objects or garbage files
that's the result
of non-atomicity of these operations
okay so just to understand overwrite
target
is true means lost
last one wins yes override target is
false means first one wins
yes or zeroth one wins or if it was
already there for some other reason
yes i mean that that would be then
perhaps lead to a deadlock and then we
need to
tweet this in some other way but what
would lead to a deadlock well i mean if
if you use if you use a log file for
synchronization
then you would use create file with
override target false
right so the first one to establish the
log file will win
and it's then that processes
responsibility to remove it at the end
so if that process dies or takes too
long then all the other ones
would be able to
see if there is an idiom for lock files
why don't we just provide that as a top
level mechanism
yeah that's that lock remover yes
yes i mean that's that's further down
this that's also this agenda i mean
we are now just talking about how to
implement these
okay but that's fine because i i don't
think that the fact that you use a file
as a lock is a hack i mean what you want
is something which is a
top level locking mechanism which has
timeouts and all kinds of things right
yeah but i mean you you have to decide i
mean
what is it you want to lock if you want
to lock output then
you need to create use a lock file in
the same file system as your output
if you want to lock something that is in
a parallel computation then you can use
a kernel uh
a normal variable as a log and if you
want to have some
worldwide synchronization then you would
use a cloud object as a log so
i understand so let's have a mechanism
just like initialization for this
locking and synchronization
that can pick its you know domain
okay let's keep going we'll talk about
this later
okay fine all right so this this
particular thing i don't see a problem
with you're implementing it
yes and on top of that i've redesigned
local objects so that they are always
all
local object operations will be atomic
automatically
and that will already get rid of all
these errors that you see
it's still the case that say you do a
resource function
in a parallel computation you would
still download 20 copies and create
the same cache 20 times but one of them
will win
and there will not be any user visible
damage done okay so hold on a second
the thread safety
means yeah sweat safety here would mean
that
if you try to establish a cache for your
resource function then
there's obviously only one process that
should create that cache
the other one should just wait until the
cache is there if they see that
somebody's already working on it
so that would be the synchronization
that
synchronization or threat safety that's
what i mean by that
so atomicity guarantees that there will
never be any
bad output and threat safety would mean
that there's only one of them
that actually does the work and the
other ones wait don't do that
right so for example in parallel
computation on multiple machines you
know i have this hacky code
that goes and installs a packet only on
one of the
kernels that is on any given machine yes
and uh
now i don't know how how well resource
function caching is already
trying to be uh sweat safe but with the
new
mechanisms we are talking about here it
will become very easy to do so
because you wouldn't
and then you see when the first one will
will then win and if it manages to write
the cache in
in a reasonable amount of time than the
other ones could just then use that
so the other ones have block yes that's
trying to use it right
okay so hold on let me let me just
understand that so we've got a family of
functions we've got the resource
functions which cache
we've got um a bunch of the data
functions which cache
i mean um anything by the package
manager
i mean it's not catching but you might
auto update and then need to rebuild the
the packlet data right so so let's see
so who was
um who is the oh gosh project well ben
ben is kind of the guru of of caching
for data functions right
is anybody here aware of that ben who
mercy yeah
i'm aware of that okay so the point
would be
that every piece of caching that he
deals with
needs to know about this because
obviously we need a mechanism
to make sure that those caches i don't
even know what's happening with those
caches right now
whether those caches are atomic whether
they're thread safe what the story is
did do you understand my point yeah i
mean i think one
one of the results of this this work
will be that we
should systematically go through
everything that
potentially uh creates
uh needs threat safety to to work uh
properly and that is all
our download download data from the
server pack let's
state that right but i'm i'm saying that
ben has been inventorying
all of our cash i see okay so that that
would be the next point to
next thing to do is to talk to face with
that yes okay
very good um now let's talk about other
kinds of random
stuff that people do i mean
here's a weird well i don't even know if
this i mean
just all kinds of external operations
like creating a short url
or i think cloud expression is being set
up to be atomic
from the the new version is atomic from
the get-go
is that correct guys yes yes
okay uh
todd are you aware of other places where
atomosity is an issue
um not surrounding files
or yeah i think
cloud objects
okay so i think we understand this point
now do you have a solution for this
point yeah i mean if you do
something like this then you you either
need
to do your own locking and that will be
the critical section that we'll talk
about in a minute
or you could rewrite your code
to use atomic operations now
also that is also mentioned further down
because it's part of
the the critical section that all update
functions with
local symbols will be threat safe in the
future
what is that so local symbol is
something stored in the local object
store
yes okay
so another area which
we could think about is our general
output functions like put
export save i mean they are all
suffering from that problem that when
you when the operation starts it creates
that
output file and then it takes some
finite time
to finish so that's disastrous and
everybody else sees
partial output now the way i solved it
for local objects is that i always
write the output to a unique
temporary file for that i need the
atomic
creation of files then when i'm done i
do an atomic rename to the final output
with override target two and so the
result will be exactly the same but
there will never be
a partial output visible right but
that's unfortunately undesirable because
if you're doing a put
to a file you often want to see it
incrementally build up
i'll put a pen but yes right
yes right and anytime right anytime you
open a file and periodically write to it
then
that's precisely the case where you do
want the partial output
well you want partial output but the put
append
it it opens outputs closes
and that should be atomic the next time
you do an open output you know whatever
the the idea okay so there's different
cases there's
you've opened a file and you're
incrementally writing using write
for example yeah that shouldn't be
atomic
as as you know you're doing a lot of
operation yeah you're doing a low-level
operation
you know what you're doing if you get it
wrong you get it wrong
um but all these things like put append
perfectly well can be atomic
that is the the new lump that they put
in
the order in which lumps go in may be
undefined
but each lump should be atomic
right in in the case where you're
writing to a file that is not already
open
because put the pen will perfectly happy
happily write to a file you've already
manually opened and set options on
in which case it doesn't close it
afterwards so now you're in the general
right
okay wait a minute wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait let me
understand that
it doesn't close it after the put append
is finished
if it was already open
yeah i mean i remember that design
decision from like 30 years ago why did
we do it that way
because you may because of the i guess
the assumption is
that if you've manually opened the file
and you may have set some options on it
otherwise why did you open it first
and so you know are we sure that isn't
from a time when there was some
different
economics of file openings and things
like that
well whatever well opening and closing
is still the most expensive part of
file operations so okay
nothing changes but yeah but okay we
have already had that case that either
you
open the file do some operations and
then you decide when you close it
or you let these functions
open and close it for you and we might
well
think about having that second case be
atomic i don't know
i mean eta has mentioned perhaps there
are more more cases where we
don't want atomicity and we should leave
it to the user just to use
that uh those functions that we now have
to maybe we could have a helper function
from for atomic
atomic off put or atomic of x
exporters okay i've got a comment here
so
let's say export for example you know i
can imagine
a case can i imagine a case
where i incrementally watch a file being
exported
is that a thing or is that never going
to work
i don't think it depends on the format
some formats yes some formats no
but it's certainly you know like for
example
it's not exactly parallel but if you
think about
rsync then rsync will oftentimes you
know write to a temporary file
so it can monitor the progress but then
it will only put it at its final name
when the down you know the copy has
finished from the remote
location yeah okay well that's a
reasonable thing i mean if you want that
then maybe it would be reasonable to
expect
or to to require that you actually
explicitly open the file
and then you do whatever you like and
then it will stay open
until you close it so that might be a
good way to distinguish the two cases
which sorry well i mean if if you if you
don't open the file before you start the
export then the assumption is that
you're not
you don't want to see the partial result
and it will do it atomically
and if you do want to see the partial
result then
you should open the file and then you do
well i'm not sure anybody will
understand that i mean we can have an
option to export
that says whether to up you know no no
you would do it before you call export i
mean
you say because your point is that
otherwise it will necessarily
well it doesn't need to be gobblable
because export knows it's writing the
file
there's two different things one is
export knows i'm writing this file but
i'm not finished yet
but i'm going to write it in lumps but
nothing else can get in the way
and say well actually no i'm gonna write
to that file instead
i'm not sure that is possible and even
necessary because this seems a very
contrived case i mean
well no no no the case that i'm talking
about let me let me give you an example
okay
so i write out gigabyte size data files
okay and i don't mind
the fact that i can see that file coming
in
i quite like that rather than waiting
and like oh my gosh
you know kind of um you know white
knuckle time is it actually going to
write it or is it going to fail
i'm saying and you don't know until it's
all there yes okay i see that yes
now which case i mean obviously
we cannot have both ways be automatic
being atomic and being incremental so
one or the other way you would have to
do something to make this happen
yes i understand i mean it could be that
um i mean i would tend to think
the case of incremental delivery
is the less common case
and i could live without it honestly
i think it's okay yes very big files i
mean if it's a small file you just don't
care
um i mean you could still have it do you
you just open the file
and then call it export with the open
file
nobody's going to do that
i don't know let off
yeah look i i
i somewhat favor an option that allows
for incremental writing
but i mean i
you know the thing i would like best is
if it's really huge
like more than 100 megabytes for example
then i would like to see it coming
incrementally otherwise it's one lump is
fine
it's like block size you know you never
see a file come in
in something smaller than its block size
and that's fine making sense
yeah i mean you you might not know how
big it will turn out in the beginning
and
it seems to me that these cases are
sufficiently rare that
we don't have to build too much stuff
but look what happens if you know you've
got a temporary file you
write writing stuff into a temporary
file the temporary file is 100 megabytes
in size
okay you flush that into its final
location
and you do that every time it reaches
100 megabytes in size you flush it into
its final location
yes would you expect that to
be some automatic or would you be
prepared for this
special case to actually do some
programming to make that work no i'm not
prepared to do any programming
why can't it be automatic it's not going
to be an efficiency hit
100 megabyte file is just not written
fast enough for this to be an efficiency
hit
uh i i don't see how this can work
atomically
because either you're copying it or
right right
because the way right the way we can
implement this atomically
is right we write it not to its final
location
and then when it's done we atomically
move it into its location
i know that's what i'm suggesting doing
here but i'm suggesting you're saying
100 at the time how do you do it 100 at
the time
short of you know copying it
each time you've reached 100 megabytes
in which case it's no longer atomic
or you're doing quadratic complexity in
yeah which is block size
okay if it's a newly created file
well it's probably more important than
to be atomic
than that it'd be incremental
so provisionally i'm i'm backing off my
my
desire for for incremental
incrementality in that case okay so we
could consider making our main
album functions atomic if
they do not operate on an already open
file in which case we shouldn't do
anything
we cannot do it i'm suggesting okay that
that makes i think that makes sense yeah
i mean this is this is what we would do
i mean we need a
helper function that just takes care of
the renaming of the temporary file
what happens okay so it's in slash temp
so if the thing is just really
no no it will have to go into the same
directory as the final output i mean
so that that's what i'm just the next
topic we need some improvements to our
tempo file creation because that's
really not
up to speed can't they
well i mean the main issue is if things
crash leaving crud around
what clears out crud if things crashed
yeah i mean there are two one is to
create it in temporary directory but
then there is there may not be an atomic
way to move it to its final destination
if that's on a different file system
which it always will be
and so usually i mean that there is a
way to do it i mean you create
the file and then you unlink it and so
if if you if your process crashed then
the operating system will take care of
that file so it's actually something i
didn't think about but
we should we should consider that online
unlinking trick
for these temporary files that's a good
that's a good point
well it's wait a minute so so you're
saying we could use attempt directory
and then we could use flash temp
we i would no we can because then we
cannot atomically
move it to its destination and it will
be inefficient because you you copy the
data
twice okay okay fine so you're saying it
should be in the
in the you know with all the tilde named
will same same directory as the final
output
and so the easiest to use would be
if we had a function that given a file
name would derive
a unique temporary right but by the way
you've also just solved
the incremental output problem because
if you want to know what's happening
incrementally you just look at its temp
file
yes so that's except if it's unlinked
then you don't see it but
so we unlinked from the get-go unlinked
i i'm
not sure what you mean in this yes i
mean that's so
i create the temp file and why to temp
file but the question is
if the process dies then the temp file
will will stay
in the file system and so what you
usually do you open the file
and you unlink it so it's no longer
referenced in the
in the directory but you still can use
it as long as your process is
that's a unix file system yes that work
on windows
yeah i doubt that would work i don't
think so it's also very weird because it
means that you'll be using
you know let's say that's a 100 gigabyte
file
you're like oh there's a weirdness i
don't even know i didn't even know that
was the thing
how do i even know there's a 100
gigabyte file there
well i mean you can you you if you look
at the at the
free space in your file system you will
you will see that exactly i mean for
example
mac os does something similar it i mean
you can have your disk
apparently half empty and it still
gobbles up all the rest for some
backups and whatnot sometimes it's quite
hard well
it's actually that's uh you know that's
using the vm and
and the virtual memory and snapshots
which is not exactly the same thing
but um right so you're saying basically
you unlink it and then you
relink it prior to renaming it or you
don't need no as long as you
as long as it's as long as you have it
open
you can still use the rest count it's
just a
thing it just doesn't there's there's no
entry in the directory right
but there is nothing reference
from the open file goes away the file
gets deleted that's that's how it works
it is a rep count okay and and do all
do all the unix file systems actually
support this
i mean i i was not aware of this
particular mode of
upper ending it well it's a very early
feature of unix file system
what's that it this this feature existed
for a long time
so it's like it's like things that exist
in us
that already existed you know two
billion years ago in the history of life
right well yes unless somebody decided
well i'm going to create an output
system which doesn't do this
but it's a very useful feature so i
all right okay but so that's probably
part of the option
that all these functions should have
about where to put their temporary files
you know something about that strategy
for the temporary files because you
might actually want in this
in that model you don't get to see the
temporary file build up but there are
cases in which you would like to see the
temporary file build up
and in which you're perfectly happy
you've got a bunch of random tilde crud
left in your directory you'll just
delete it
making sense yes that could be an option
of the
new create temporary functions i agree
okay yes okay so then okay
so now what's all this stuff okay so
that so
that creating temple files so to make
this work what we just talked about
it needs to be easier to make the
temporary files
in some given directory and actually
from all they
suggestions down that it's only the last
one that i'm now
uh uh suggests because that was just my
my my thinking about and i finally then
found an easier way to do it
so now we had we had a create temporary
file
which what suggestion should i be
looking at the the last
red point there or new rather old
function create temporary at the
little bit further down right there yes
that's that's the new one so
all you need is yes given a file
create the tempo file in the same
directory right
with some option make it visibly
invisible and every operating system has
its way of hiding files like the dot
files
in unix which we should use and
i think that would be a very useful
function now the question is can we call
it create temporary that is something we
do some time ago now the old one
doesn't have arguments and the new one
would have an argument so it would be
possible to reuse that create file well
temporary without an argument would
presumably to create something in the
temp directory yes but we
we deplicated that function if you look
if you go back to the uh
i know i know i know it's now in create
file it says yes a create file
shouldn't do both of these it's it's
strange
and so i i i would suggest do we
to revive the old creatures
with an argument yep i agree just for
the creator file or directory
yes not a good name
i'm sorry what it doesn't suggest
whether you create a temporary file or
temporary directory so it's not a good
name
or maybe a temporary file file why not
create things
okay okay option for create file
to indicate the location
yeah but it's it's kind of strange
because you cannot give a name template
for create
create file i agree
temporary file seems the right thing yes
by default does it make it give a new
one each time let me argue the
alternative here
why isn't this create file option make
temporary goes to true or something like
that
which uh you know does whatever
right that takes that as a template and
creates the associated canonical
temporary file
let's not put it into create file it's
really a different operation
create file is something people do for
you know for whatever
reason but temporary files are something
weird ephemeral unlinked funky
heuristic whatever
and this would be a file name and it
would create a temporary file
that is a unique temporary file
associated with that file name
right it has a uuid in it or something
or whatever it is to make it unique
yeah probably a few characters right for
files you can create is rather limited
so
that you already do that with our create
temporary we just use these
these visible names m000 whatever
and i don't want something better yes i
mean i think we can redo
create file i think we should use
something which is more like a uuid
and create whatever create file this is
an ugly temporary file name
well that's create temporary that's not
create file
i know but doesn't create file do the
same thing in the main the main problem
the main problem with create temporary
is that
we do not create these tempo files in a
sub directory
but in the main temp directory so they
that is the value of dollar temporary
directory because it's per user
on mac oh no not the m but not the m
prefix i know which is the wrong prefix
now
and i think we should be a little bit
more you know
possibly we should even you know reveal
ourselves in these names
you know wolfram dash some uuid we
should use a subdirectory for our own
temporary files okay fine mouse link
already does that that's
the the one case that doesn't clutter
your temp directory
okay so what should the name of the
top-level directory in which our temp
files
will from temporary files or something
i mean just call it wolfram
right it's in the temporary directory so
just fine
okay that's fine now that's that that
would that would help
we'd use the clutter and then it can be
shared by
mathematica and desktop and yes player
yeah i mean yes i mean these files do
not have any
anything valuable to them right so
the only thing that matters is that you
create a new one every time you you use
that function
would it be a uuid or would it be i
think it should be your idea that's much
safer you don't have to there's no race
conditions on you ideas well
they're just so ugly so long i mean
yeah but how often does it come in but
but listen if you end up with a
collision
of too far is the file creation atomic i
guess it is
yes it will be and so it just iterates
until it finds a unique name and that
iteration
chain is very short if you start with a
six digit to end of number right
fine all right okay it'll be a minimal
uuid
basically we could use some shorter
prefix like
mg5 or something i mean it doesn't need
to be universally unique it
needs to be unique per file system i
know that i realize that i realize that
i'm just saying
it should look like a uuid because it's
less confusing and i think it should use
the same you know
characters probably as in the uuid maybe
we could use all all i don't know
whatever this is this is using all
things that's mac os the okay
so i get it i understand i'm just saying
why don't we just use
to keep these names short why don't we
use 36 characters and we just
increment through them yeah
i don't know whether we want to i mean
do we want to start with zero zero zero
zero zero or do we want to
you know if we wanted to get a random
value then there's less less
less collisions it's just it's just a
hash whatever it generates
okay fine fine all right okay so that's
agreed what that is okay so then
create temporary file will create a file
using and then it could have a second
argument which is the style of file so
to speak
the style of hiding so yes
no like that that could say for example
dot file
well i mean i'm not sure that that makes
sense right on unix it should be a dot
file on
on windows it should be okay attribute
yeah the default should be automatic i
mean
all right fine i mean i think more
important as some other aspect like that
the tempo if i would have the same
extension as the base file so that
we don't run into problems with file
types
and then you would have an option should
it should it i don't think it
necessarily should
because if it isn't i don't think most
programs do that because you shouldn't
be able to open it with an opener of
something
until it's finished but if you're going
to be exporting to it
export will need to know what the format
is
no but but i'm saying the only thing
this file is just holding a bag of bits
until it's ready to be moved into its
final location yes but i mean what
i think ita means is if you use a file
name in export
export will look at the file name and
decide what to do i
understand but it's never going to see
this file name this isn't yes it will
because
export atomic it will see it
export will be invoked on the temp file
not on the final output
okay fine but you can feed export it's
explicit
uh but then then it doesn't behave the
same way or it's not guaranteed to
behave this
okay it is not a good idea to have a
file which is an
incomplete file that's supposed to be i
don't know an xls file or something
and it isn't we have a dot xls
and most programs do not do this
okay i i don't think that's true well
i've listen i've been in many situations
where things crashed
and i had to go try and find their temp
files okay
and essentially always the temp files
did not have the file extension
yeah yeah let's see that's okay i think
it's common to have whatever whatever
dot part
as the extension they usually add some
maybe
dot xls.gmp or something like that well
that's possible never
it's not something like that yes that's
possible but
i i don't think that style of hygiene
makes any sense because
it's already a temporary directory and
you don't need to hide anything there
it's not a temporary directory it's not
it's in the same directory
as the final file is going to be
assembled it is not a temporary
directory
that's a different branch we're talking
about okay
yes okay
i think i have it we have it under
control now so there's a comment here
from
on our live stream about temp files can
have issues on network drives and
synchronization through dropbox onedrive
etc
so consider defaulting to the user's
local temp directory well if
you're defaulting to the directory that
the file is going into
oh i see there's a question of create
temporary file
what is its default directory that it
uses
is it a user specific temp directory
or is it a system template it has to be
the current working directory
no yes if right
if it's creating it in the same
directory as file name
no no no no no no you missed a point
here there's
three cases there's three cases here
case number one
you are creating a file in a known
destination directory
then the temp file has to be created in
that same known
destination directory for ease of
of moving cop you know whatever it is
there it's thing number one
thing number two case number two is
you know nothing you're just creating a
temporary file somewhere
and there is no definition of where
it's supposed to go you just want to
hide it away somewhere you're going to
use it for some internal purpose
you do not want that in your home
directory that would be horrible
i i don't see how create temporary file
can
have different semantics from create
file
yeah i think this is we are not talking
about
create the create file which
defaults to the temporary director here
the question is if the file name you
give
as the as the target
then it's very clear that it's it's that
no no stephen
the file name could be absolute and then
it's clear it's the same directory
must be relative to the same directory
as you can see i completely agree okay
so the case that we have not covered
is create temporary file open bracket
close bracket
where does that go directory
what's that temp temp actually that's
what i think yes
but i okay but i don't understand what
this
is i guess i get what i mean i suppose i
write because if create temporary file
is supposed to be creating some you know
temporarified name a file which no
it's it's not it's create temporary file
of a file name
creates something which is a temporary
decorator name
of that file okay a temporary file of no
arguments
is doing the same thing that the current
this create file is doing okay
but the question is is that and how is
it different from
that create file it's not necessarily
okay it's not it's it's repeating that
functionality okay
but another thing that would be sorry no
no but but the point is which i think
our
live stream person is is commenting on
is that it may not be smart
to try and put create a temporary file
in a central slash temp directory it may
be better
to have a hidden area in the user's home
directory which we know the user can get
to
right that has those things in it and
that for example
i don't know if you're using let's say
dropbox
okay and i've got a bunch of directories
that are put on dropbox do i want the
temporary file to be in my dropbox
directories or not
i want the temporary file to be to be
you know synced over with dropbox
or not well do you want to
move it further do you want to rename it
you will have to transfer it
if you do anything so i think for for
what we are looking at here the create
temporary file
with the file name argument will always
be the same directory
and it should work with anything that
has that has locking
semantics and that is most most uh
network file systems
will presumably cause it not to be
synced by dropbox correct
dropbox will be will be syncing based on
things that are not sure
broadbox probably doesn't support that
tweak i don't know i mean it's
none of it might support a second
dropbox just scans its directory
periodically and copies
things you know to the server or from
the server fine which is good because we
don't want it copying
a partially constructed temporary file
that was unlinked
right but is this thing unlinked right i
mean it's
how how is this thing unlinked no
this one is not unlinked this is okay
our internal well maybe we need an
option to this
how do you refer to an unlinked file
well you you have to have it open before
you unlink it so you just
you open it and then you unlock it and
then you can still use it
like normally
is create temporary file then returning
an an
output stream object no it would create
a file descriptor and you hold
it okay but hold on this is a different
operation okay wait a second
different operation is open a file
and unlink that file
okay so so we're doing an open write or
something like that
and then we're saying some kind of file
unlink and then the open right
the file descriptor the the file pointer
is still valid pointing to that file
which is no longer listed in the
directory because it has been unlinked
is that correct yes i mean in fact i
wonder whether
it would already work now i mean if you
open a file and then you
use a delete file whether it would still
still work or not okay that's a good
question to answer
but i mean that's a very very obscure
way to do it yes but
i mean i i agree i mean it's not
something we should
and i mean you're right i mean we cannot
say create them
create a temporary file and unlink it
because create temporary file will not
open it it will just return its name
and it's an up to you to open it and
unlink it if you so desire
we don't need to to support this in this
with this function
right but okay so create temporary file
open close
i think should create a temporary file
in some hidden directory of your home
directory
yes or no no
or should it be in a central slash temp
directory
whether it's stem center or not depends
on the operating system on on the mac as
you just see here
you have your own uh temp directory on
unix you
typically don't have your own so we
shouldn't we don't have to
well whether you've you've modified your
environment variables but by default you
don't
also need to just on over there
they want to create temporary files
i think that's the issue you should be
able to indicate
where you want to create them and if you
don't then they are created
whatever all right okay i mean we had we
have dollar tempo
directory and that is i think what we
should use i mean we don't need to
invent something new here
one thing one thing that would be nice
also is to be able to
get the name without creating the file
if we have this default that's realistic
i mean i think that
you know i mean it is possible it's it's
just not atomic i mean
right right by the way i just did the
experiment of
uh of deleting an open
stream and apparently it closes it and
then deletes it
so we would need to know yeah so we need
a separate file unlink function
if we're going to do that i mean if you
wanted to check
whether the temporary file exists for
for a given file
what if you want to check whether it
exists whether the temporary file exists
you want to see
did my operation crash and there's still
some hanging
file here you want something that will
you know tell you where the temper file
would be if it didn't exist so you can
use filex's queue on it
yeah i mean you you get the name back
from temporary file that gives you the
name of that file
okay listen i think we got to resolution
here
so let's move on well let me just offer
the quick observation now that i think
it should be
like unlink stream file right because
it's really
right you need the open stream in order
to unlink it in the way that would be
useful
yes what are some other operations on
streams
what are they called i don't think it's
correct
well i have the wright family the reed
family
and said options i think are the main
things we have on streams at the moment
okay we could have it an option right
right unlinked or something yes it could
be an option
for a stream why not yes
set stream position is uh
stream position are sort of
the i think the two main operations that
are specifically on streams
i mean stream unlink can you link a
stream that is unlinked yes you can
presumably
yes so there's basically
is there a name for this is is this
stream
connected to a file under directory or
not
right that's the question right which
you know some streams never are right if
it's the stream is a pipe
it's never backed by a file right
well so the option you know backing file
or something
for a stream we could have such an
option and if it's none
then it's unlinked and if it's a name
it's a name and you can change the name
if you want to
that would be my initial suggestion
right although i think that would only
work if it started its life
as file backed
right i don't think you could suddenly
change a pipe to be
is that true i don't know i don't know
that
you can redirect pipes at the beginning
of a process i don't know you can do
that in the middle
okay we can determine that okay we need
to move on
synchronization unlocking okay so this
is now
what we can do once we have all the
homework done with the
atomic operations so this handles
threat safety so you want to have a
block of code
and guarantee by agreement that you're
the only one
working on that block of code i have to
say i would i would much prefer to use a
term like thread safe
than critical section critical section
is just like
it seems like it might be a piece of an
airplane or it might be you know
anything the i mean we already have it
for parallel computing and so what what
i'm proposing here is to extend that
notion
so that the lock object can now be
a file or a local object and in the
future
perhaps even even a cloud object
okay but i think we should change the
name critical section
i'm telling you it just it just it tells
me nothing
right i mean for the for the typical
user
who isn't steeped in your distributed
computing
lingo it tells you absolutely nothing
what is it it's thread safe is that
right but it's not necessarily threads
right threads make things
not thread safe this is just one of them
okay but this is you know this is
lock evaluate or something locked that's
that's a that's that's that's good
i mean it could be something in the
block family
i'm not sure exactly what but well but
the possibility would be locked
evaluated so this would be in the family
of remote evaluate and
you know all the other evaluate things
this is a special version of evaluate
that is somehow locked or could we use
the with
i mean we have now we have with clean up
and with
with lock synchronize is another word
these things can use well let's just
understand exactly what it is
so the first argument of this is
the the locking the thing that records
the lock
yes right so lock to evaluate with
well okay what about with locking
and then there's the lock location and
there's the expo
that makes sense yes
yeah i mean i mean that depends on the
lock location so we have i mean
it's not necessarily a file no i
understand
we know that it could be a variable
lock lock well lock it lock
object locking object lock object yeah
yes what happens to the existing symbol
arguments well these
these are all these will also be these
will be lock
objects that are local to a parallel
computation
i don't want i mean
okay i mean having a new name would
would give give me a chance to rethink
that
but i mean
my current design is completely
compatible so at the moment we have
three
log object types we have files we have
local symbols
and we have shared variables
each for its own purpose
okay so so you just didn't list the
yes because that's alright yes i forgot
to list that because that
forgot those sorry the the current
critical section which supports shared
variables for parallel computation
right so right there's a form of
critical right the currently documented
critical section is
critical section of var comma code or
var list comma code
i have no idea how this works i mean i
never use the stuff
and i use parallel computation every day
so
it's a bad sign by the way i was very
happy i used jesse's um
uh batch job submission stuff to aws
yesterday worked beautifully
very nice actually anyway
there um
in fact i might even still have
something running though um
the only thing i the only thing i need
to know from that is a better way which
i'm afraid is not made easy by anything
to estimate how much it's going to cost
to run some particular computation
because i had no idea i mean i think it
cost like two bucks but it might have
cost 200
so it might have cost more than that i
don't know yeah i mean it's no no
no wonder that doesn't make it easy to
find out
well if you don't know the cost doesn't
that mean you're a lisp programmer
what oh there there's an old line
by uh it's not bjarne it's it's some
c advocate that you know the car
uh the list programmer knows the value
of everything in the cost of nothing
okay i'm not sure i necessarily
completely get that but whatever
okay set shared variable what does this
do
well this turns the access
into a variable that is maintained on
the master kernel and
every sub kernel will synchronize
its its value now
this i mean this is textbook example if
you look on the right hand side if you
look in the expo in the critical section
then you see a read access to xs and the
white access
and if you do it without the critical
section then you will not
it will not be sweat safe and the
parallel kernels will
override each other's values and so this
part of your computation needs to be
protected with a lock and so that's what
critical section does
i don't understand if you say with
locking
here yes what's very obscure to me
is this variable that only appears
inside that locking mechanism right
so to me it's like i want a one argument
form of with locking
yes and in fact if you look on the left
hand side till the last
part of my agenda because we've talked
about this before and i've talked that
out
so in certain cases you can actually
specify the thing you want to protect as
the locking argument and the system will
figure out what to do
but this is of course limited to things
that
work as lock objects so you don't get
anything other than files and local
objects and
cloud cloud objects and with local
objects it will no longer be necessary
because they will be sweat safe
i'm confused i'm confused why do i need
this first argument
critical section here in this case in
this piece of code here
i could just make a symbol because it
knows
i'm trying to take this critical section
not another critical section there's no
synchronization with anything outside of
this
it's just you know with locking this
particular thing
x s equals x s plus one is done with
locking
and yeah but i mean if you have other
parts of your code that
work on a completely different variable
then you don't want
these two to wait for each other so
critical sections i i know i know so
it's essentially lexically scoped
and basically there's no lexical scoping
because this this will happen all over
the place
especially if you use files as long
excuse me i i know i i realize that i
realize i'm saying
i'm saying i'm saying look i'm saying
if in this case we're using a variable
as a lock
right and all i want to do is to have
this single critical section
you know yeah but they're not there
there are 32 of those
in your 32 parallel kernels
i understand that i understand that but
but what you're saying is i've got one
piece of code here
that says parallel do of with locking
exper okay and so the idea there would
be
comma 10 or something okay so what would
be the point of that the point of that
would be
that this is saying
this has to have locking so that the
parallel kernels
can't execute these experts at the same
time which is the same thing you get
with this lock here
but you there's no reason to specify
that lock in this case
in this case no but if you go to the
neat examples then you see the
the dining philosophers which are
counter example
because there you have you have
variables which represent those forks
i i understand philosophers and so this
case does not work in
this i'm well aware right i'm well aware
i'm saying that
the simple case right involves no
philosophers
and no forks right the simple case
is just the the philosopher every
philosopher
is on their own right they're not
do you understand what i'm saying
they're not yes but i mean
it's not even guaranteed that all of
these i mean
parallel evaluate is a simple case but
there's no reason these
these kernels couldn't run different
pieces of code
and so that case where every parallel
colonel
does exactly the same lexical
uh critical section is not a very
common case why why i mean this is
exactly what i would want
if i was doing something
look for example let's say i'm doing
parallel parallel
map across a whole bunch of things and
i'm trying to maintain
one variable that is let's say that
parallel map
is testing uh a billion cases of
something
right and i'm accumulating successes
yes then you don't need all of this you
just need a shared variable which is
automatically sweat safe
what you need is the dxs and you you can
simply say append to xs
on each parallel kernel i know but what
about an alternative form of that code
which is more functional
where i just say with locking you know
append to x
something in here where i don't have to
declare this variable
yeah but if it's not shared then nobody
sees
your results so
well but no but what if i was throwing
it to a variable
no that's not correct i mean oh i see
you're saying
that that each of those things is inside
the parallel kernel
but if i if if this expert did a thing
that was global
in fact how do i refer back to a
variable that's inside the master kernel
at the moment you have to declare it as
a shared variable
that essentially giving access to all
parallel kernels of the
variables in the in the mastercard and
i mean there could be alternatives i
mean thought about
callbacks and things like that at
various times and i think now we
probably have the technology for it
but i mean another thing you could
synchronize what your expo
could write the results to a file
and then you and if you use the same
file you need to
lock access to that file and so far
the only way to do it is to use that
existing critical section in the future
you will be able to use the
new uh we lock and just specify the file
as a lock
i know but you only need to specify the
file that's the point i'm making
if it's lexical you need to specify
nothing
you just need to specify the operation
you're trying to do because
somebody invited you off you have two
processes that are not connected as
parallel kernels just running
running completely separate there is no
notion of lexical scoping
i i understand that i'm saying for the
case
where with locking is inside parallel
computation
this can be done lexically
if you have two different functions and
two different things you're absolutely
right these processes cannot communicate
the whole point is in a
you know in a parallel computation like
this we have a master kernel
with sub kernels and so we understand
how the communication works
right therefore we can do this without
you having to specify where the lock is
because
this lock there's just some randomly
named symbol that you've made up
you do not need to know that name yeah
but if you
i mean
well maybe i mean i need to think about
whether this
this notion of no lock is is useful and
even well defined because i mean i i'm
always
seeing things like you have several
different types of critical sections
so you need to sort out which is which
no doubt
no doubt but i'm saying the lexical
version of with locking
just says whatever that extra is it is
it is you know there is locking
when you execute expert that's it that's
all it's saying
okay so it would be i mean it would
amount to some
default lock variable right yes but it
isn't always the same default it's
picked differently
so if i say with locking of expert and
then i say with locking of expert two
okay so and then i say here and then in
the middle here i've got
a a foo here then
you know what that's doing is it's
making those two things be locked
independently yeah independently yes so
i mean maybe you just need an experience
do i have to lock name from that i mean
it's fine whatever i mean okay
i'm beginning to see what i mean i'm
still
what we should take from this meeting is
that with locking is a reasonable name
and we have we will support the two
argument form
right the two by the way this one
argument to argument form is reminiscent
of the way that confirm and close work
yes have a a a lexical form with one
argument
and an explicit form of two arguments
okay yes
i have yet to see anybody use the two
argument form
right yes i mean because i mean
i think whenever you have non-local flow
of control then
you probably uh i mean if it isn't
lexical it's very complicated
yes okay all right so that that that's
that's a suggestion there but let's
let's understand so that's the main
thing for critical section is that right
that you would
yes the time constraint because that you
need that to
to detect and to handle uh deadlocks
and so the idea is that what happens
when the time constraint is up
well then then it returns and and
signals gives gives a specific return
where it all
timed out and then you have to deal with
it i mean you have to decide whether you
want to break the lock because you
assume
that the other process has died or
whether you want to
wait some more or whether you want to
return to the user with an error message
i mean that that is
so who who decides that where do you do
that you need
i mean the next you you look at the
return value of critical section and
then you see what happened
and every piece of code has to make up
what to do i mean there's no unique
best solution right i mean for example
if you if you use this for for creating
a a cache you might decide to break the
lock and just go ahead with the cache
yourself what does the code look like
outside of the thing can can it use the
confirm and close mechanism for example
to deal with what happens if the lock is
broken uh that's actually a possibility
yes
i mean at the moment it just returns
either returns the result of code or it
returns dollar timed out so it follows
the same principle as all the other ones
that catch and i mean it's in a way
some some some uh some uh
well actually i mean what happens if i
say time constrained
of um you know pause of two comma
one for example that will return dollar
aborted
yes i mean that's unfortunately nothing
a very good
thing to do i mean to you to generate an
abort i mean here
time constraint is more it's more benign
i mean i i can
i can detect it without i understand but
but
but confirming clothes are looking for
particular things
so yes let me let me think about whether
that could be made to
that would actually be i mean with with
clean up is another possibility because
you
usually have to to clean up after a
deadlock and so on so let me let me
think about it
okay possibly what the code looks like
around okay
that's a good that's a good that's a
good point yes okay
all right what else do we need to look
at here well i think we've covered
with uh this this threat protect i think
we now have with lock
with lock which i think is the better
although slower
slightly lower lower level version
i mean here what is this well the idea
that that's the other approach
you instead of making up the name of a
lock to use
you let the system decide what kind of
lock it needs
you specify which resource you want to
protect
so i i want to do output undisturbed
output to a file
and so i say protect this file and let
me do my thing
well but actually the the word with
locking could perfectly well be taken
to mean the thing that's first the first
argument is the thing that is being
protected and lost which
yeah but this is much more limited
because i mean there are only
three different cases for the lock
object but the code that you want to
protect could do anything right i mean
it could
sure but what's the difference in your
thread protect here seems like its first
argument is a lockable object again
yes but it's not the lock file it's the
object
that you manipulate in the code so
i just wanted to bring this up i don't
think this is a very good idea or very
useful
but it's just something that came up
about about a year ago when we talked
about this
but i think with locking is is a better
way because you really need to think
about what do you want to use as a lock
you shouldn't leave it and and the case
of local object isn't even necessary
anymore because
they will be sweat safe and so that's
right
okay ethan on our live stream asks when
the new version of parallel tools is
coming
didn't you just send out mail like a
week ago yes
in fact the next 12 months we built
should have fingers crossed the new the
new parallel tool stuff
and but of course i mean how many years
is that
okay six years i mean i didn't work on
it for six years but i mean enough
coming for six years yes yes and i i was
able to
i mean i now understand a lot more about
these things and i was able to
reuse a lot of code uh everything i did
for these cluster kernels and so on
so i think it will be good and it's not
finished yet but uh
it's it's a good it's a good thing to
have in 12.3 and i will add more stuff
to it
before and so remote evaluate and
and you're also dealing with the the
evaluation menu in the front end yes
yes that's that's the third i mean at
the moment we have remote evaluate and
parallel tools which use the same
new kernel specifications and
the ps2 resistance the final thing will
be the front end
which is more of a management task than
technical i think
but uh well no i don't think so i think
it has ux stuff that has to be untangled
yes i mean yes the ux stuff will be the
same
it will just be the ux for specifying
kernels
and the main thing is technical because
the front end
has its very specific ways of dealing
with these kernels it has these extra
links to the kernels which nobody else
uses
for for the dynamics and stuff like that
and these need
need a little bit of thought especially
if you go over the network
here with ssh or his wsdp server but i
think now
it's it's very realistic that we can do
it
okay good all right let's see
the question just a comment here
from valued on a live stream what about
an atomic attribute for symbols that
would have this locking behavior be more
declarative
i mean that that's the equivalent of set
shared variable yes
but that's relevant relevant when you're
in a multi-threaded yes i mean normal
symbols are
so don't need or benefit from this
because you cannot access them from
anywhere else i mean
we're talking about local symbols and
they're all automatically
atomic and of course cloud
objects would be a big
another thing we need to look at and
once we have this and so
i think set chair this is the answer i
mean if if you need to talk
to with with parallel kernels then
search shared variables are often the
the best way to do it because you get
the synchronization automatically this
whole parallelism
synchronization etc thing i am i am
slowly working my way towards this grand
new theory of how all the stuff should
work
based on what we've learned from the
physics project and ideas about
reference frames and all this kind of
stuff
not ready yet um and and it also
relates to all these causal graphs and
uh you know because the causal graph is
the story of what can affect what
and it's something a causal graph i mean
interestingly
what in our physics project you know we
have this notion of space-like
separation and branch-like separation
space-like separation i suspect is the
analog
of being inside one process and
branch-like separation as being is the
analog
of being in different processes and um i
don't exactly know what the
um need to think about what the whole
isomorphism operation that we have
of branch-like separated things being
merged
what that's all like about but i mean
that probably ties into uh
uh uh consistency and uh all the
difficult questions about of about i
causal invariance which we've studied
greatly in the physics project and which
is what leads to relativity and things
like that
is eventual consistency they're the same
concept okay good
yes i mean needless to say there's
nothing new ever
i mean eventual consistency is a little
bit closer to confluence than just
causal variants causing their answers
generalization that works for
infra infinite time processes um
but yes that's um uh
and once you have that you have this
notion of equivalence between reference
frames
once you have eventual consistency
different reference frames
that uh basically
do things at different microscopic times
it doesn't matter because there is
eventual consistency
but nevertheless the way that you
actually think about programming
can be vastly different depending on
what reference frame you're using
and essentially you can be in some
boosted frame
where i mean again i don't completely
understand all these analogies yet
um where
i don't know i mean it's like it's like
you can do you have a bunch of
of things you're you're following let's
say you're traversing some graph or
something
you can be doing depth first breath
first whatever else
again i you know this whole study that i
just did of combinators
is somewhat revealing of these kinds of
issues as
i mean i'm currently in the midst almost
at the end of studying multi-way touring
machines
which one would have thought were
trivial but they are completely not
trivial
they're not only are they not trivial
actually roman this is a question for
you or anybody else on this
i have been trying to look up the
history of non-deterministic turing
machines
and so far as i can tell they
you know they kind of gradually seeped
into computer science
first there were non-deterministic final
automata which are
you know 1959 were early papers about
that
and then um by 1970
you know np completeness was being
discussed and the and the idea of
non-deterministic turing machines
was kind of emerged in the discussion of
in the definition of mp completeness
but it turns out as far as i can tell
nobody has ever looked at you know
people looked a bit
at small turing machines so far as i
know nobody has ever looked at small
non-deterministic turing machines
which i have now been looking at and in
fact one of the surprising things is
that the
i have pretty good evidence that the
simplest universal
non-deterministic turing machine is
incredibly simple
much considerably simpler than the
well you know the simplest deterministic
turing machine we know
as a result of that effort of mine
a deck in a bit ago is this thing which
has
uh two states three colors so i've been
i've been on the hunt for the simplest
non-deterministic turing machine which i
believe to be
significantly simpler than that but why
is this all relevant
well the whole point is
you know which actually i have not
described in the thing i'm writing
right now is the relationship of
parallel computing
to non-deterministic turing machines
right because
essentially what's happening there is
yeah i could probably formulate a bunch
of these things in terms of thread
safety and so on i mean like like
you know if i were to pull up the random
pictures that i have where are they um
where is it um
see
not very exciting but these are these
are um
uh these are non-deterministic turing
machine
multi-wave systems multi-way graphs and
those are halts
halt states so this is one which halts
but it has many different ways to halt
so it has no causal variance but there
are other ones but i might not have
pictures of here
which have um uh oh there's a remote
batch job um
and uh
anyway so i don't know what the
significance of this is for our current
purposes but i am
i'm slowly working towards some kind of
grand unified
new theory of parallel of distributed
computing
that makes use of ideas like causal
graphs
and um uh you know notions from physics
so i don't assume that there is
communication between any two of these
processes right no every branch is
separate
okay every branch is doing its own thing
the the merging of branches
is assumed it is assumed that if two
branches end in the same
go to the same state they will merge
which is not obviously something that is
implemented in computer systems
i mean eventual consistency is the
statement that you will always get to
the same place
in other words you imagine
that you follow only one branch in
typical
you know you there are multiple branches
that could be followed depending on what
what microscopic ordering of
asynchronous events occurred
but you imagine that in a particular
case only one branch is followed
the case of quantum mechanics is the
case where essentially every branch is
followed
and um that's what you know if you think
about quantum turing machines that's
what they're trying to do
and um anyway a lot longer longer story
but um
uh uh right anyway not ready yet but but
i i think i'm going to have a really
pretty nice general theory of this
um but it isn't ready and i don't know
how it's going to relate i mean it'll be
nice to think about
how this theory is going to relate to
what we
you know to being able to do because
right now
our parallel computation is mostly
you know send the same thing to all
these different sub kernels
right yes so the issue is
but and then the sub kernels i mean i
just need to think about how this
i don't know yet anyway so to be
continued um all right we should wrap up
here
good i think we made good progress here
by the way does anybody
i'm sorry if anybody happens to have any
thoughts about the history of
non-deterministic touring machines now's
the time to tell me about them because
i'd like to
anybody know anything about that no
unfortunately not
fair enough um
okay thanks a lot everybody thanks to
folks on the live stream
and uh uh somebody just sent something
here
um
um i noted sent some messages but i
this was a while ago and i don't think
there's anything to do with them now
i wish you'd said something
okay all right thanks a lot